how would you say you and kanye's
relationship is at this point because
like obviously if you've been to wyoming
a few times you've got to have some
rapport with them
i like that man it's dope you know i'm
saying i think we got a you know pretty
good relationship like you know saying
if i need to you know
tap in with bro that's that's nothing to
do before me and
just the love
the man's show you know saying i'm
forever grateful like when i slap on a
man wrench
you know what i'm saying i was out there
for a week or two longer than that
probably that's crazy i've been with him
and you know saying i've been to dr dre
house
[ __ ] with kanye first time watch like
i'm saying [ __ ] with ya have me at dr
dre's like coming up with hooks and [ __ ]
for dr dre you know what i mean
here on release little music and [ __ ]
like he was playing he pressed play
button on
some fire like
i've heard i got a funny ass story about
that night too please tell us the story
okay yeah give us the dre story
not yet i got a dress
i don't know if that's
if it's okay
[ __ ] want that out there but man how
was drake he's crazy
drake cool ass dude man and you know
what's so cool about it
he actually remembered me and i should
like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] remember me like
because i get there
like it's funny because
i was i was i've been on a ranch and
i've been
before i went to the ranch like
um in wyoming
yeah before i was in wyoming like
yay had a studio
uh in calabasas somewhere somewhere out
there like you know what i'm saying and
i was out there you know working on some
music and [ __ ] with him
but in yay studios like real churchy
vibes and [ __ ] like you know i mean gay
on this you know you're christian and
stuff so
it's not really the same type of vibes
that i may particularly be used to like
we ain't drinking and smoking in the lab
and right all the homies and you know
what's that it's like
you know you got the choir in there and
like people from like church and stuff
like there so it's like it was kind of
different from me too
because i never really like
worked on like you know being i guess
like christian rap or stuff like that
like
you know my my thing is i'm grimy this
all the time you know what i'm saying
like please never pl please the sidebar
just quick don't ever put out a
christian rap album please
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying what no i'm
just saying like i never i never i never
did so it was kind of just new and stuff
to me right mm-hmm and uh so i'm out
there and i'm out there for like a week
you know what i'm saying recording going
there every day
and i just like yo man
so when we go to we go one day i'm over
there um
recording long story short i'm over
there a year studio recording and we go
to you know the engineer yay wasn't
there the engineers stopped beating like
yo i just got a text yay wants us to
come over to dre's because i think you
know him and dre was working on some
stuff for the album
i'm like
you want us to
you know what i'm saying like yeah we
all going over there so we go to dre
house
and go in there and i'm just sitting in
there and it's like
it's mad people in a room
but like i'm seeing people smoking and
drinking and [ __ ] i'm like oh this one
that's where i needed to be that's what
i've been missing right you feel me like
[ __ ] i start rolling my back walled up
mm-hmm you know i'm saying that drake
kind of like stepped off from the board
of [ __ ]
turned around you know what i'm saying
it look like oh okay yeah i remember you
because we i met him for the first time
at the uh
the star unveiling for 50 cents yeah you
guys were there right so that's when i
met him and he remembered me from that
day
and you know that's bucket list [ __ ] for
me all right just for dre to know who
you are
right just for dre to know who i am like
that [ __ ] just like different for me i
heard the speakers at his house are
crazy
this man's studios aren't real i
couldn't believe what i was seeing i
heard it's so crazy i heard like his
speech like he got the craziest speakers
nah but i've heard about it i have a lot
i know a lot of people who have been
over there and they just say oh man that
was the i couldn't believe i was there i
couldn't even believe i was there
real talk like
shout out to dre man he showed love you
know simon they're
you know saying uh
with snoop oldest son
a couple of dre homies and [ __ ] like
that like it was just love like
and you know we ended up working on some
stuff actually wow you know man
hopefully we'll hear it
hope so hopefully hopefully we always
hopefully i can work on more with them
yeah like dr dre is like a
big inspiration i mean [ __ ] he just put
out a six-pack um of records last week
off of gta
which was done to work with dre
yeah now drake learn from him and just
watch him yeah his create i heard his
creative process is like very meticulous
very bro i was watching that [ __ ] and
i'm just like bro i get it like his ear
for like this is the frequencies and
yeah it's so crazy like the [ __ ] that
you see in like the maybe in the videos
and stuff where
you know i mean now that i'm shooting
videos and stuff you know how we might
like pretend yeah yeah you might twist
it now he's real
he's really like like that
he really liked that
right very into every little the
smallest detail
[Music]
that's what i hear genius this is just
amazing to watch and the studio that he
got set up is just so ill like
i couldn't believe i couldn't believe
that i was there i
wrote so i can't believe like
creative process wise
from what you witnessed from dre to
being
in multiple sessions with yay yay seems
more of like a
on the fly guy like i've seen him
recording everywhere from some crazy
studios with choirs to like
a mic in a hotel room like a lot of like
uh uh the good the the cruel summer [ __ ]
was like just in a room yeah you know
so like what what what would you say
like yay's creative processes that you
kind of took from that was like a little
different ah
yeah he liked that too like the same
thing i was saying about dre like
every little detail he's you know it's
very particular and very thought out
and you know he knew what he wanted he
know the direction he wanted it was
crazy like i was fortunate like my first
day landing in in in out there and as
soon as i get there go to the ranch and
like
he already in the studio and he got you
know we all in there
and the man made like
seven beats in front of her in front of
me and benny axe benny that's crazy
like just like quick we wanted anything
like it was like we was in there all
night
it was like a couple of hours if that
like the man made seven beats fast as
hell
that's wow
like i was like when i got back to the
you know where i was staying after we
left
like and mind you we in his like in his
personal space of it like his house
or whatever this [ __ ] is
this is in wyoming yeah it's like this
[ __ ] is crazy like watching him the
whole ass ranch how he do it like he how
he like it's just dope
it's just it's just real dope man to be
able to say yo i watched
kanye create
music in the studio dr dre create
like i'm watching dre make [ __ ] a
beat in the studio it's crazy
they
that's real [ __ ] not a lot of people on
earth
what is dope to see like i feel like
quiet as cat man you're probably one of
the very few people on the planet that
can say
kanye's co-signed me i've worked with
him eminem's co-signed me
jay-z's co-signed me yeah and we could
go down the list but like we're talking
like songs with everybody man it's crazy